[Music]
hanno is is a wonderful science fiction
writer and and the the praise that his
fellow science fiction writers heap on
him is is one of the clear signs Charles
Stross the the quote is I think he might
be better at this than I am which is
certainly high praise indeed
but in addition to his literature he has
a PhD in string Theory's currently CEO
for helix nano nano which is a synthetic
biology start up the space here in the
Bay Area and he's natively from Finland
but has been speaking and writing in
multiple languages for most of his life
his new book is called summer lands we
want to thank borderlands books here in
san francisco or selling it along with
other books of Hondas tonight and he
will be signing them after the talk
please join me in giving a big round of
applause for ha new lemonade
[Applause]
hello and thank you for having me
Michael after all the upcoming talks I
definitely feel an attack of the
imposter syndrome coming on so so please
excuse me but thanks to Michael also for
setting this up and digging up some
amazing period details from the 19th
century that we'll get to and thanks to
Otto for growing these mysterious
stirring things that will also be
explained later on and thanks to Andrew
and Forrest for the great job with the
with the a B so for if you've read my
work and/or followed my my writing
career you'll know that for much of that
I've been concerned with what's known as
the technological singularity and I'm
sure this audience is mostly or
overwhelmingly familiar with it but it
is a term that was coined by Vernor
Vinge who actually also has a great long
now talk that you should check out and
what it is is a point in sort of maybe
not too distant future where the
progress of technology accelerates to
the point where all our predictions
about the future become meaningless it's
sort of like the technological
equivalent of dividing one by zero and
in the sort of present-day conversations
usually it means means the emergence of
some kind of super intelligent AI that
will either destroy humanity or create
heaven on earth and some people are
worrying about us actually actually
accidentally building that AI right now
now that's maybe a bit ambitious but
certainly there's this sense of an
approaching technological rapture and
the people who are serious about the
singularity often sort of also referred
to some kind of technological
immortality being achieved through mind
uploading or even the super AI creating
simulations of people who've lived in
the past
Ray Kurzweil the author of a single RT
is near and director of engineering at
Google talks quite openly about wanting
to essentially bring back a simulation
about it off of his dead father now I'm
not actually personally a hardcore
singularitarians which may surprise some
of you but I've always
be very intrigued by the concept and
took it on as a sort of a challenge to
see if I could write a meaningful
fictional story about that would be set
after the singularity and that led to to
these books starting with the quantum
thief and its sequels and as I was
writing them I became aware of this
Russian thinker called Nikolai Fedorov
who'd sort of anticipated ideas that
sounded very much like the modern idea
of the singularity already back in the
1890s and in the quantum feed box that
was just a little side note but after
finishing the books I kind of was was
intrigued by it and started wondering
whether there had been times in the past
where it felt like the singularity was
coming and and what did those what did
what did it feel like living those times
and it turned out that this was very
much the case and the result was my
recent novel Summerland which just came
out it is a spy story set in an
alternate world where a very different
kind of singularity has just taken place
scientists have proven that the
afterlife is real and can be contacted
by a radio and it was inspired by
real-life Victorian spiritualists ideas
from four dimensional geometry and
etheric physics and today I want to tell
you more about all those crazy ideas and
tell you some stories from real history
and maybe we can discuss all together
what those stories can teach us about
our present-day worries and hopes about
the single RIT so to start with let's go
back to back in time 180 years - to 1838
and to the invention of the electric
telegraph and so 180 years ago Samuel
Morse sent the first telegram in the
United States and that was across just
two miles of telegraph wire but
Telegraph sort of exploded at an
exponential rate and just ten years
later there was 6,000 miles of telegraph
cable in the United States so it's 6,000
miles in
ten years and Tom Standage has actually
called the Telegraph Network the
Victorian Internet and I think that's a
very good parallel there was this
explosion of growth Wild West period of
sort of different competing technologies
and different companies and ultimately a
sort of consolation when the Western
Western Telegraph Union was formed and
it became sort of a Google of its time
and by the year 1900 it controlled a
million miles of telegraph lines now
very close to where Western Union was
headquartered in Rochester was a small
town called Heights Ville and in March
31st 1848 something quite strange
happened there these these two sisters
Kate and Margaret Fox started receiving
messages from the afterlife and the
messages came as wrapping noises that
that that had a code so sort of multiple
wraps for no-one wrap fur fur fur yes so
quite a lot like the Morse code in the
telegraph and initially the girls told
their family that the messages came from
this creature called mr. split foot
maybe maybe the devil but later sort of
changed their story and said it was the
spirit of a peddler who had been
murdered in their in their home and as
it happened the Fox family was friends
with a quite an influential radical
Quaker family that lived in Rochester
and and they and the Quakers got very
very excited about the possibility of
directly communicate with the dead and
and they sort of formed what became the
core of the spiritualist movement and
suddenly there was this explosion of
mediums the Fox sisters got hundreds of
imitators they themselves became very
famous and Horace Greeley the
newspaperman and politician sort of took
took them under his wing and the timing
was sort of right for something like
this the US was going through what is
now known as the Second Great Awakening
it was kind of a Protestant religious
revival that emphasized a personal
relationship with God sort of came with
fascination with supernatural and and
and romanticism so people got very
excited when suddenly there was this
what you could describe as an open
source religion that from
direct lines of communication with the
dead and because the early spiritualists
were associated with groups like Quakers
and and Universalists they were also
very much into social reforms abolition
of slavery women's rights and so on and
and mediums actually mostly women so so
that sort of gave them a new kind of
voice that helped drive some of those
those issues but when I kind of looked
into this what really surprised me was
how closely the language used to
describe mediums I was associated with
telegraphy so here's a period drawing
that describes a spiritual Telegraph
sort of crossing the Atlantic and some
mediums actually started using Telegraph
transmission hardware so so they first
they took sort of existing telegraph
hardware to to channel spirits and then
actually started building their own
hardware for for contacting spirits so
so here's here's one one example which
is an alphabet wheel for communicating
with the dead but it's actually modeled
after a contemporary wit stone design
some of the earth wants the early
alphabet wheels that made it easier for
a telegraph operators read read the
incoming message so there's this very
interesting feedback loop between
between the hardware that the mediums
used and the hardware that the telegraph
operators used now the ultimates
Hardware hacker amongst spiritualists
was this very fascinating character
called John Murray spear and I want to
tell you a little bit more about him I
wasn't able to find a good period
picture of him but somehow Michael was
able to uncover his business card so so
here is the front page of his business
card so Jones Murray spear was born in
1804 in Boston and as a young man to go
with his brother he became a
Universalist minister and he was really
prime example of one of those second
Second Great Awakening reformers he was
a prisoner rights activist he helped
prisoners released from jail to get jobs
he helped to establish the the
Underground Railroad so as we helped
escaping slaves to
to go to northern northern states he was
actually nearly killed by an angry mob
when he defended a slave who is accused
of murder and he was initially quite
skeptical of spiritualism
but in 1852 he had this very powerful
southern experience he fell into a
trance and was contacted by a group of
spirits who called themselves the
electrolyzers now that sounds like a
superhero team or a super he loved in
villain villain team but and that's what
he pretty much what it was so these
spirits included such luminaries as
Benjamin Franklin and Thomas Jefferson
and and other very very smart feet
people and but their message wasn't just
about peace and love or what had
happened to to John's loved ones they
had had a lot of time to do thinking in
the afterlife
and they had come up with entirely new
technologies and they started dictating
designs for these inventions that they
wanted John to build that we're going to
change the world now one problem that
Spiritualist generally had and which
john had and the spirits had was that
there were so few mediums to start with
and it was also quite hard for a medium
to stay in this trance state so to solve
this problem john teamed up with another
medium called elizabeth french so in
addition to being a medium she was an
electrical experimenter and one of the
things she had done in the past was try
to revive lightning strike victims and
victims of drowning by connecting them
to batteries and together they made a
suit bower powered by a large set of
batteries a kind of spirit armor that
was supposed to amplify the mediums
thoughts electrically to give the medium
of better reception or to turn somebody
who wasn't actually a medium into a
medium and so they experimented with
this suit and wearing the suit they they
also realized that they could transmit
thoughts to each other and that led to a
very concrete business idea that that
john then had
which was Cyrus field famous
industrialist businessman had just been
given a fifty year monopoly to lay the
first transatlantic Telegraph cable and
John and his spirits thought that this
was a really bad idea because it
essentially gave private ownership for
this communications infrastructure that
enable could enable all kinds of
oppression and and and censorship and
who knows what things we can very much
relate to today and so in response the
electrolyzers proposed that John should
build a decentralized network of mediums
building a sort of mesh network of
towers where mediums would sit wearing
this spirit armor of course and passed
telepathic messages from one another and
this would be free to use to everybody
so sort of a network neutrality would
apply and and and John Johnny is
Associates actually went out and tried
to raise funding funding for this but
sort of failed to to get it off the
ground but they they did open source all
their designs so they they published a
newspaper article that said that all
these instructions will be available to
whatever parties who are disposed to
attempt the practical realization of the
scheme so to any intrapreneurs here you
want to do an IC o---- it's all all up
for grabs but John soon got busy with an
even more ambitious project and that
project shown here on the left was
called the new motor or the new motive
power so John together with a group of
followers went to a remote location
called high rock and they started
building it and it was basically a
perpetual motion machine it was going to
collect limitless amounts of energy from
the spirit realm and replace the seem
engine but it was also going to have a
soul and it was going to be able to
self-replicate
make copies of itself and completely
transform all fields of Industry so in
other words it was exactly kind of super
AI that Elon Musk and other people are
are now worried about and making it
included some quite elaborate rituals
basically one of John's female followers
was supposed to symbolically give birth
to
to the electric infant that was going to
be the soul of the machine there are
some amazing descriptions of the ritual
that they perform to make the machine
come alive John wearing the spirit
Armour and suddenly there being this
umbilical a threat of energy that
connected him to the machine that the
mediums we were present could could see
and apparently the machine did start
moving these these rotors on top did
start slowly slowly spinning but sort of
an exponential takeoff did not happen
and also John's wife Betsy wasn't too
happy to hear that there had been some
kind of sexual element to this ritual
and and as a result his reputation was
ruined and and and finally to that
insult to injury a gang of local young
men got together and and broke into to
the High Rock the house and erected the
new motor and you know so there was an
actual angry mob so and for all we know
they stopped this a spiritualist
singularity from from happening but this
did not discourage John Murray Speer he
just did a pretty hard pivot to to into
making spirit powered suing machines and
there's a bit of an interesting
historical context there in 1840 Cyrus
Howe had invented the first modern suing
machine actually based on a design that
came to him in a dream and and it sort
of sort of gave a lot of women a new
source of income and and sort of East
they're they're jaggery but it was still
hand cranked and John and his friends
thought that they could use the new
murder or or variant to to drive it
instead and I'm completely impasse in
emancipated women from from this sort of
hand hand hand based suing and and he
started the company and this time it was
a bit more successful they did actually
succeed in in building a suing machine
it was initially clockwork powered but
they they sort of also fell back to a
hand-cranked design but it was much
cheaper than than the competing versions
so they did have some success in in
selling them but then the civil war came
and and John decided to take his family
and
to England for a while so he thought
there would be a new market there for
suing machines and he also wanted to
make connections to some local
spiritualists because the spiritualism
movement was taking taking food there
and his sort of the other side of his
business card from that period where
where he talks about being guided by
these beneficent spirit intelligences
and and sort of refers to see on sees
that he held in his house in Regent
Square every Wednesday and and I kind of
want to to want us to travel now with
him to to Britain and sort of elaborate
a little bit more on what was going in
there and one of the very frequent
attendees in Jones Sciences was a
gentleman called Alfred Russel Wallace
who shown here with Charles Darwin and
together with Darwin Wallace of course
was one of the creators of the theory of
evolution and they published the key
paper on that together and like Darwin
Wallace or went on all these brave
expeditions to collect huge amounts of
zoological samples including sort of
famous flying frog but unlike Darwin he
actually came from a quite a bhoot poor
working-class background like like John
Murray spear and later in his life he
ended up selling most of the samples he
had gathered like 80 80 thousand
different species of beetles for example
just to support himself and he was more
of an idealist than Darwin was and he he
was actually pretty uncomfortable with
some of the implications of evolution
and he was convinced that there was
something about the human consciousness
that wasn't just a product of evolution
that and that survived after death and
so he got really excited when people
started to practice spirit photography
so here here he is with his the spirit
of his mother and so taking taking
pictures of spirits using the the new
photography equipment that was available
was a common practice and this convinced
him that there was indeed life after
death and like many Victorian scientists
he became a committed spiritualist so
and Wallace is actually a great example
of how a lot of the British
intellectuals felt at the time theory of
evolution was really this nuclear bomb
that exploded amongst them if you were
really serious scientist you couldn't
really ignore
but taking it taking its implications
seriously was almost untenable because
it implied that there was no God no
afterlife no basis for for human
morality so many of them like like
Wallis sort of ended up grasping at
straws to to find ways to reconcile
science with the afterlife and the
center of those efforts was the Society
of psychical Research founded in 1882 it
actually still exists but doesn't quite
have the stature that used to here's one
of its founders Frederick Myers who was
a poet and philosopher who coined the
word telepathy and what SB ARS mission
was to was to take a hard scientific
look at ghosts mediums apparitions
psychics and so on and its members and
early presidents included a pretty much
all-star cast of politicians artists and
scientists Nobel laureates John Ruskin
HG Wells Mark Twain William Thompson who
discovered the electron William
Gladstone many others and they they
really sort of sort of had a hard go at
collecting a lot of data about what
famous mediums were able to achieve what
sort of contact with ordinary with dead
the ordinary people had what sort of
experiences tell up to see people people
had and so on but some questions really
still remained like if there were really
spirits where were they
and if the soul was not the product of
evolution then what was it made of and
that was sort of something those answers
to those questions could maybe be found
in physics and one of the most prominent
physicists of the SPR was this guy
called William Crookes with his amazing
moustache and his greatest invention is
the thing he's holding there the cathode
ray tube or Crookes tube as it was also
called which later allowed roentgen to
discover x-rays and also became a key
component of the radio and sort of an
ancestor of the vacuum tube in the early
computers and so on but he was also very
committed spiritualist
point he actually traveled to the u.s.
to interview the Fox sisters that we met
earlier and concluded that they were
definitely the real thing so so he then
also sponsored mediums who wanted to
come to - to Britain and at one point I
was he had a visitor this American
medium called Henry Slade when he got
another visitor from Germany a an
astrophysicist called Johann zellner and
Zollner had an hypothesis about the
afterlife that he wanted crooks and
Slade to help him to test and so what
zelner did was he gave Slade an
unknotted string so a piece of string
that that was just a loop with the ends
sealed together with wax so that you you
couldn't couldn't open it and asked him
if the the spirits that Slade was
communicated with could could make a
knot in the string and he turned out
they could slate gave gave him in short
order a sort of sort of a knotted
version version of the string and then
Azolla retired some other experiments
could the spirits sort of sort of make
two solid wooden rings joined together
seamlessly and sure enough they could
and and a few other similar tricks now
you might think that that Slade was just
a very good magician but Zollner
actually became convinced this was proof
that spirits existed in the fourth
dimension so just to let that sink in
for a moment it's great success due to
the force dimension so a few basic facts
from from topology and geometry in three
dimensions if you try to introduce a
knot to an unlit string the either the
string has to be open or or the string
has to somehow pass through itself but
in four dimensions the string actually
has room to go around itself and you can
in four dimensions sort of introduce and
not into into a closed loop without
without without opening the look and
Zola wrote his conclusions up in in a
book called transcendental physics and
whatever you think of his conclusions he
definitely had a huge impact on
Victorian era thinking about the
afterlife it sort of popularized the
idea that that spirits could actually
exist in the fourth dimension and
moreover afterlife could be studied
using the best method
physics now this talk actually almost
became a talk entirely about the fourth
dimension in the Victorian era there's a
fascinating character about cold called
Charles Hinton who popularized a lot of
these ideas and I kind of don't really
have time to to go into it but in the
Q&A please ask me about the fourth
dimension Charles Charles Hinton but
there was a lot of other things going on
in physics at the time so James Clerk
Maxwell had just unified electricity
with magnetism so it created this set of
famous equations that that perfectly
described all electromagnetic phenomenon
and and it also his equations also
predicted that there should be these
electromagnetic waves propagating
through through empty space which really
confused
Victorians because nothing should be
able to propagate through through empty
space and so this was explained through
the idea that there was this substance
called luminiferous ether that that
filled all of space it was everywhere
inside us in in in the vacuum of space
everywhere this sort of extreme leaves
of ephemeral but but perfectly non
viscous fluid through which all sort of
wave motion like like light propagated
and by that time point people had also
discovered atoms Mendeleev had come up
with the periodic table of atoms so
people knew there were different kinds
of atoms but nobody really knew what
what atoms actually where and Lord
Kelvin one of the sort of giant
physicists of all time came up with a
really intriguing theory so incidentally
he played a key role in building that
transatlantic cable that drummer a spear
was so worried about and he's wonderful
ideas was this so if ether was this
perfect fluid what if there were
vortices in that perfect Floyd and a few
years earlier visit is called Helmholtz
has shown that if you have a perfect
fluid with a vortex that vortex is sort
of a permanent indivisible object just
like an atom but then how did you
explain that all the all the atoms where
we're different from one other one
another and and so Calvin took the idea
one step further and proposed that Adams
were actually not eat vortices so
vortices that loop back into themselves
and and and make notes form knots so if
you imagine his smoke ringing that that
is also not that's pretty much the
visual idea he had in mind but he worked
it out mathematically quite well and he
is actually a vortex not that people
made in a lab in University of Chicago
just just this year so so it's
definitely a real real phenomenon so
Adams as vortex notes whatnots what's
Calvin's idea and people started
following up on this most prominently a
Scottish mathematician called Peter Tate
and and he had another brilliant insight
so so if Adams our vortex knots what if
you could reproduce Mandela's periodic
table of elements by classifying all
possible knots so he set out to develop
the mathematical tools needed to do that
and and actually invented the still very
active ongoing discipline in mathematics
called knot theory but he failed to
match up his table of knots with the
periodic table and at first he was
discouraged but then when he thought
thought about it a bit more deeply he
realized that besides Adams there was
something else that was eternal and
indivisible and and unique that was the
soul and with his collaborator Belfer
Stuart he published a book called the
unseen universe where they essentially
argued that a soul every every every one
of our souls is a knot in the ether just
like Kelvin had proposed and seems to
create these knots like Ziller had shown
unique access to the fourth dimension
then obviously God and spirits and
angels and perhaps other supernatural
beings we're all four dimensional now
it's worth pausing here a little bit I
mean this is all pretty wild stuff at
least to two hours or from our
present-day eyes but people like Wallis
and crooks and Tate and Kelvin I mean
that there weren't cranks I mean there
were some of the greatest biologists
physicists and mathematicians of their
age perhaps of any age and there were
great system builders who sort of had
this
overarching needs to fit everything
everything together including life and
and and afterlife and and everything and
sometimes they were credulous especially
when confronted with very charismatic or
sometimes attractive mediums but if you
look at it from their point of view in
their lifetimes everything was changing
extremely rapidly new discoveries like
x-rays and the telephone and radium and
and things like that we're being made
all the time so how could you be certain
that they're wearing some people who
could actually talk to the dead and what
if you could good and what if you could
build devices to contact the afterlife
and so it really felt like some kind of
approaching singularity some kind of
moment a very special moment of
accelerating change now one of the most
respected scientists who was also
spiritualists was this gentleman here
who's sort of doing some exercise in his
home sir Oliver Lodge he very much
pursued both electromagnetic research
and study of spirits and telepathy as
two sides of the same coin
he's today famous for being one of the
pioneers of radio as well as inventing
the spark plug and the loud speaker so
he invented the device called the
coherer which was like a simple act
romantic wave detector and I spent much
of his later career sort of competing
with Marconi in commercializing the
radio and he was also an active member
of the the SPR but he was very respected
he gave a lot of public lectures and he
was seen as this very very reliable
scientific figure
so when Frederick Myers that one of the
founders of SBR that we met earlier I
decided to do an experiment as is sort
of I felt his end of his life was
approaching he gave a lodge a sealed
letter that was only to be opened after
after Myers his death and he was going
to try to pass on a message from beyond
that that was supposed to be matched to
the contents of the letter and it seemed
like the experiment was successful so in
1901 a group of women at the very
highest level of British society started
receiving messages from Myers via
automated writing and
at least according to some
interpretations the messages matched the
contents of the letter that Lodge had
been given so so one of the kind of key
mediums where some of the key mediums
where Alice Fleming up up on the left
he was the sister of a sister of the
famous writer Rudyard Kipling and Aleks
also co-authored some of Kipling's early
Indian tales as a side note Kipling also
wrote a great little short story called
the wireless which is about contacting
the off light with radio another medium
receiving messages from from Myers was
Winifred Coombs tenants up there on the
right also a very remarkable woman a
suffragist
Member of Parliament and later the
British delegate to the League of
Nations there were a few few others
others as well and they although all the
letters from Myers we're shared amongst
this very elite group and the hub of the
group was the sort of most arts
gentleman on the bottom bottom left
Arthur Balfour who had been the
president of the SPR and at the time
when these letters were arriving he was
the Prime Minister of Britain and later
he got the nickname bloody Balfour for
sort of cruelly putting down unrest in
Northern Ireland and he was actually the
one who signed the declaration to found
the state of Palestine so a pretty
important guy his brother Gerald in the
middle middle was sort of equally
accomplished and they had a third
brother Francis who died very young at
the age of 30 many years before while
climbing Mont Blanc and he was known as
for for his for his talent in biology
and people were saying that he would be
the successor to Darwin but he died
before he could realize that but in any
case this group circulated all these
letters arriving from Frederick Meyers
from beyond from the afterlife via
automated writing and it was kind of a
shared hypertext if you like they kept
all this very secret and these letters
were all interconnected seemingly even
though different people received them
there were symbols that recurred from
classics from the Bible from Shakespeare
and so on and there were so many
interconnections that ultimately the
group became entirely convinced that
this was real as Meyers talking to them
from the afterlife other people started
talking to them from the afterlife
including Jane Littleton who
being sort of this lost love of arthur
balfour when he was young dad also died
very young and also francis ball for the
brother had the sort of third ball for
brother and there was a this big picture
this this plan or a story that started
to emerge from the letters and so so
what myers was was saying was that a
kind of Darwinian evolution continued in
the afterlife and and as Myers and and
Francis Beaufort had ended the off life
they had gotten a lot smarter and they
had been a sort of scientific revolution
in the afterlife people in the afterlife
had perfected the engineering of souls
and in fact Francis Balfour was leading
a team of spirit scientists she were
designing a perfect soul a sort of
perfectly engineered spirit child whose
task would be to deliver humanity from
chaos and and of course this perfect
soul only needed a vessel to be
incarnated into now again a bit of
context this was 1912 at this point and
the British elite had this kind of
widespread sense of crisis approaching
chaos in the world
there were socialists and anarchists and
feminists and suffragists and sort of
sort of unrest in Europe and all these
alliances unraveling so it was pretty
clear that somebody somebody needed to
to save the world so two members of this
group Sir Arthur's living brother
Gerald's in the middle and Winnie friend
up on the right that took one for the
team and they had an affair although
they were they were instructed by by the
spirits to have an affair and waited for
it's much older husband actually knew
about it but but sort of maintained
stiff upper lip and and said nothing
about it
and so Winifred got pregnant and gave
the birth gave birth to the vessel of
this perfect engineered soul and I just
can't help thinking how how remarkable
this story is story is I mean this is
happening happening at the sort of
highest levels of British politics in
society
combining all these these ideas about
eugenics and evolution and engineering
applied in this very otherworldly
context so here is the spirit child at
the age of one and then at the age of
of 30 and I was called Henry Combe
Tennant's born in 1913 and as far as we
know he wasn't the Messiah he didn't
save the world from from chaos
unfortunately but he did have a pretty
interesting life
he studied in Cambridge he he met
Wittgenstein was taught by Ludwig
Wittgenstein the famous philosopher
fought in world war ii and got
imprisoned escaped a German prison camp
by himself fled across Europe ended up
working for the British intelligence
service for mi6 together with kim Philby
who would later be revealed as one of
the most one of the deepest soviet moles
double agents of all time and it was
really Henry's life that kind of made me
made me decide that Summerland had to be
had to be a spy story and he was an
inspiration for one of the protagonists
now later on Henry's life sort of quite
it down and but in the 50s he did try to
contact his mother Winifred through
through through through through medium
probably to complain about about the
kind of weird circumstances of his birth
or or to high expectations and and and
it's not clear if he succeeded but soon
after that he did go away to become a
Catholic monk and lived for the rest of
his life in solitude so it is actually
the kind of biography you can never put
in fiction because nobody would nobody
would believe it but one of the
fascinating facts about about Henry was
that he was in Cambridge at the same
time as another interesting historical
figure Alan Turing and they probably
attended some of the same lectures by
Wittgenstein now Turing of course is the
famous mathematician who has a pretty
good claim for being the father of the
the modern computer but if you kind of
look at Turing's writings carefully you
find that he's not this ultra
rationalist mathematician that you you
might imagine any more than the sort of
Victorian scientists where he had this
tragic lost love in his teenage years
called Christopher Morcom
who died young and then Turing like
the other characters in this story then
spent the rest of his love life mourning
and in letters to to Christopher
Morgan's mother one of those on the
right nature of spirit up there he talks
about his belief that there is something
beyond the body a spirit that a body
sort of attracts into itself and which
is maybe later to be able to move on and
it sort of sounds quite a lot like what
the earlier Victorians were saying about
how they visually envisioned a
scientific afterlife and it goes deeper
than that
so one of his best-known papers or
perhaps his most best-known paper on
computational machinery in intelligence
which is the one where he describes what
we now call the Turing test where which
is sort of a criterion for whether a
computer can be said to think or to be
intelligent or not where you have a
judge trying to distinguish a computer
from from a human just through through
teletype in which is quite a popular
competition amongst AI people today and
actually quite similar to how how the to
these telegraphic mediums communicated
with the spirits as well but if you read
this paper closely there is a segment
where he argues that if there are such
things as Souls then a sufficiently
complex computer should also be able to
attract a soul and be immortal in the
same way that that human beings are and
well it seems that right now there are
many people trying to do just that so
there is in recent years a so-called
recreation service industry has emerged
which tries to create chat bots that
recreate either dead or living people to
the point where maybe one day they can
pass the Turing test and they already
have hundreds of thousands of users so
maybe that's one thing that is different
today from from the Victorian era when
we start getting crazy ideas about how
the afterlife might work we can actually
try to build it but having sort of
looked at these services personally I
suspect that maybe hundred years from
now they will seem sort of strange and a
bit misguided to us sort of in the same
way that that sort of Tate's unseen
universe or Spears new motor seem to us
now
and actually in the end I sort of like
what John Murray's beer was doing so he
was building these spirit machines but
his goal was not to achieve
transcendence or immortality but to free
slaves to emancipate women and power
suing machines it's all very practical
and mundane problems and even if your
technology is powered by spirits that's
that's what it's really for
but but there are these these times in
history when science and technology
change faster than we can really handle
and then we do have this tendency that
you see over and over again in these
stories to mystify them you turn them
into into kind of religion you look kind
of some sort of for some sort of
transcendence or or Savior in them a
spirit child or or a messiah or a new
motor that can save the world but really
in the end it's all up to us thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
so when was it when they were creating
the was the spirit child what was what
was his was a child and Henry Henry
Henry tomb tenens how did that interact
with their Christian faith or was a
resist do you see how religion Veena's
are there are there still people that
are you know holding religion how does
it intermingle with with the the the
more spiritual side yeah that's a very
interesting question I I think sort of
the the what's sort of interesting about
spiritualism and how it emerged is it's
sort of in the u.s. it had this boost
from from technologies like the
Telegraph driving social change and then
in Britain it was really sort of an
meshed with the the sort of empirical
scientific method so the idea was that
this was actually you know maybe maybe
maybe you just didn't necessarily have
to all reconcile all of it with
Christian beliefs
I mean Arthur Balfour was quite
skeptical about Christianity but but if
you had something that that you could
actually empirically verify yourself
then that was something you could you
could rely on and we it's fascinating to
see this going on at the upper echelons
of society did you get in your research
any sense of what was happening at other
levels was there a spiritualist
fascination going on in the
working-class or was it traveling no
absolutely I mean I mean you can see
that that's how it starts in the US I
mean that's that's really sort of sort
of this more working-class movement
usually usually coupled with socialism
and there was there was some of that
also also in Britain one of these sort
of early utopian socialists in Britain
was a guy called Robert Owen who was
much more working-class guy who was
actually studied studied studied with
who he was also a spiritualist so there
was I mean I kind of chose to focus on
on the
upper-echelon because there's this
interesting transition from from the
working class to to the very scientific
and political elite but but there was
definitely similar sentiment all across
the board and and actually what the sort
of really interesting thing that I
alluded to was that there were writers
like like Hinton who popularized some of
the these more highfalutin scientific
ideas to to the popular audience so a
lot of a lot of people were reading
about these things in in in newspapers
and periodicals and so on and yeah so it
was very widespread and Joe you're out
there with microphone right Joe's got
the microphone so get-get Joe's
attention he will be passing around and
I'll be calling on and also for folks
that are watching on a live stream you
can put your own questions in to the
chat there so one more question for you
go to the audience so as you said these
are some of the leading the leading
minds of the time and they were very
accomplished in traditional science and
then we're also in areas we would
consider fringe right now were there
areas where you kind of saw them bounce
back into more conventional science or
things that progressed scientific
research because it's still a time when
there were a lot of discoveries going on
or did it kind of stay on the fringe and
never we don't get a lot of benefit from
from this imagination now well I think
like if you look at a figure like like
Sir Oliver Lodge I mean I am I don't
know if he wouldn't necessarily have
pursued real life electromagnetic
research had he not also been interested
in sort of spirits and mediums and
figuring out not just sort of how
machines could communicate but how
brains could communicate without an
intervening medium so so I think that
that same framework was driving that
that research as well I mean there were
others who were more skeptical like
James James Clerk Maxwell he was great
friends with Peter Tate was Barrett was
wasn't buying any of it Darwin ascended
accion Switzer ovolo Lodge and he
thought the person the lady lady used to
be invalid Palladino was a complete
fraud so not everybody kind of bought
into this but but like there were
definitely many major figures we did and
and and I think
was a feedback loop that that probably
had some benefits to to actual
researchers and in some ways maybe had
kept their momentum going because they
were they were they were exploring more
looking for the spirit feedback yeah I
think there's a general phenomenon in
science that we we often fail to
recognize which which is that sometimes
scientific discoveries do come from from
sort of really weird weird
unconventional ideas like Copernicus and
Kepler introduced the heliocentric model
not because they they had really any
scientific or empirical basis for it
because but because Copernicus thought
that there must be this central godlike
force that that radiates from the Sun
that that sort of keeps everything in
it's in its orbit and and the circle is
perfect so so therefore everything has
to be in circular orbits and so there's
kind of this this beauty or or mystical
argument almost and and that does
occasionally recur almost even in modern
physics and feels like string theory
where you make these arguments from
beauty and elegance which which aren't
necessarily empirical at all I think
hold on one second they'll turn it up
for you just make sure to hold it very
close so I know that there's a
spiritualist Church here in the city at
Franklin and clay and I'm just wondering
if you in your research have occasion to
go there or if you looked into that
church at all is that like the only one
in the US or a group of them so I didn't
go there that the book and the research
were mostly the research and the writing
were mostly done in the UK and Belgium
so as I wasn't living here yet when most
of it was written but but John Murray
spear for examples did spend quite a bit
of time in San Francisco and I'm sure
there are many spiritualist churches and
communities all across the US and and
the world still but I haven't visited
them personally and if all this stuff
are there are there remnants that you
see through lines that interview through
to today I mean do you see any sign that
that whether and in in Europe or
elsewhere that there are people that
stop believing oh yeah I mean there's a
actually had one review of Summerland
that that sort of basically loves loves
to writing but but says that all the
metaphysics is completely wrong and and
that sort of gives references that I
should I should look into that will sort
of put me on the right path but no so
the of course like they're there is like
I don't think I don't think spiritualism
is as near mainstream as it was in sort
of Victorian times or after World War
one but it's definitely still a real
existing system of thought and there are
people who genuinely very much believe
that they can contact the dead dead but
but sort of the I kind of focused more
on the the earlier stuff because there
the idea in Summerland really is that
let's look at a world that diverges from
our world around 1890 and then let's see
see where it goes I feel as though
you're in a very soft way drawing the
parallel from the 1990s to the 1890s or
the world where you know the singularity
or the juice arrow that we were gonna
believe in these things to a level that
that imbues them with the power that
they may not have and I but I'm
wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit more on that the parallels of
the 1890s to to know yeah absolutely
so I mean I guess in the beginning I
laid out my cards by saying I'm in order
not a single eret Aryan now it's
undeniable that we've had incredible
advances in recent years in AI and
machine learning but I just feel that
there are these failure modes of
thinking that are very easy to fall into
where you sort of project or imbue the
new technology with a supernatural power
and and quite quickly from that you
progress into technological after lives
and and an immortality and and raising
the dead and and then you are not very
far from religion and and I and they do
you feel that there are some signs of
that in the current current discourse
and maybe some some vocal welcome
working minorities who think along those
lines but but it's sort of interesting
to really look at the historical
parallel history doesn't repeat itself
but it but it rhymes as is often often
said I think it's rhyming definitely in
that area so I've had the pleasure of
rector reading Summerland so he two
questions but the closely related summer
Landers have completely well worked out
worldview based on the spiritualist
model did you and you're a physicist it
reeks of both physics in spiritualism in
a kind of good way so did you actually
work out the entire physics of the
interaction with the physical realm and
the spiritual realm Summerland in
Winterland and secondly there was a book
published in the 1920s called the
mystery of space by Robert T Brown who
was a quantum physicist who were the
first and who was trying to actually not
get the afterlife but the notion of
something bigger than we understand and
the mystery of space was his both
mathematical and physics treatise the
book virtually disappeared but he found
it's part of the roots of something here
in San Francisco the Institute for
noetic science hmm which also had a
similar view of something bigger than
humanity that we were in touch with so
question did you encounter the mystery
of space and you actually work out the
whole physics so if I take the second
question first so yes I I did did
encounter the mystery of space now is
this the Robert C Brown who who was an
African American poet living in Brooklyn
no no because then maybe I'm confusing
meet somewhere else but that but yes I
did did encounter the the mystery of
space I wasn't aware there's a
present-day descendant oh wow I
I would love to let see that and and yes
I did sort of try to to the best of my
ability to work out at least some of the
physics not down not down to sort of
great eagerness level of actual field
equations and lagrangians but but to to
sort of kind of I mean I think actually
one of the the core ideas in Victorian
physics was being able to visualize
things and and give everything sort of a
mechanistic explanation to be able to
visualize things that things in your
head so how sort of different if they're
extremes or vortices would interact or I
mean Hinton Charles in turn I refer to
was fantastic at this so so I did read
quite a lot of Hinton's works which Rudy
Ricker has edited and compiled and I
tried to get to the point where I could
sort of visualize different types of
ether that existed in this world and and
how the souls in the afterlife
interacted with the living and some of
the physics so let's talk a little bit
about your book as I'm sure tour will be
thrilled to hear at summer land to
talking about Hinton and tape throughout
the whole thing so so you got kind of
captivated it seems like by this
research or how did you know you were
gonna write a book the whole time or
what was the process of and and tell us
something about the arc of this project
coming from your research into what
became Summerland yeah it was quite a
long project in the sense that there was
quite a lot of reading in the beginning
but I think at the point where I where I
discovered Henry Combe tenens I realized
I had to had to write something about
something something like this how the
sort of Victorian society collided
collided with the afterlife and
individuals were that were involved and
and then it took a bit longer to to work
out what that story should be like and
then then realizing it had to be a spy
story was also a bit of a revelation and
both because of the intelligence
community connections of some of the
characters and general connections in
Britain between the occult and the and
the intelligence communities but also
because given that it was going to be
such a metaphysical story in some sense
being a spy is about uncovering layers
of reality that other people don't know
about and I'm digging deeper and deeper
perhaps
powering further and further layers so
so that felt like got quite a good
metaphor for what it was what it was
happening in the book and then then he
took some it actually took a fool draft
that that my editor and I weren't happy
happy with which sort of got entirely
rewritten until it sort of emerged in
its its current form and we haven't even
talked we've talked a bunch about the
Brits but we haven't talked about the
other side they're competitors and you
want to say a word about that who the
other absolutely so so so there's a in
Summerland there's sort of this cold war
also going on in the afterlife between
between the British Empire and the
Soviet Union and sort of switching into
real history for for a second there's a
very interesting thread I didn't have
time to go into into but how all these
ideas especially about the fourth
dimension fed into the early days of the
Soviet Union so I loaded two to the
Russian cosmas nikolai fedorov who sort
of anticipated the singularity and
resurrecting the dead through
technological means in the 1890s but
during the Russian Revolution he had a
bunch of followers in the soviet union
prominently including a guy called
leonid crusting who was kind of kind of
like the main fixer for the for the
early Bolsheviks he he was responsible
for for getting getting all the
financial resources for the Bolsheviks
and negotiating some of the early early
trading deals but he was also a fervent
follower of fedora and he believed that
Lenin had to be resurrected so so he has
a bunch of friends they called
themselves God builders so they believed
that Lenin had to be cryogenically
preserved and this was like he died very
he did I mean even while I was still
alive they actually started thinking we
need a religion that that and there was
this idea that they would they would
turn Lenin into into sort of a Godhead
of this new religion and so they had
they they tried to cryogenically
preserve him that that didn't entirely
work out so he was embalmed
they had this artist to determine who's
who early early Soviet artists who was
really fascinated with
dimension design his tomb and it was
originally supposed to be the set of
cubes that represented a hypercube and
and this comes from sort of the hint o
nyan thread thread of thinking about the
fourth dimension as the afterlife and
and and basically every Soviet home and
a factory was supposed to then have a
replica of this cube as a sort of altar
to to Lenin and and then sort of Stalin
came along and he he sort of pressed the
reset button by killing most of these
people but but or having having them
projects so but there was kind of you
could argue that there was this really
interesting relationship between death
and the Soviet thinking there was
actually this this tool that they could
be used to reshape shape humanity and
stalling of course applied it very
traditionally for that purpose but in in
something the world of Summerland
a lot of those early god builder at
tents actually are successful so they
succeed in turning Lenin into this
godlike being who then watches over a
very different kind of Soviet Union and
Stalinist of ends up having a very
different role so and is there truth to
the competition obviously without the
spirit world sigh but is is there is
there a thread of truth to that or how
actually think about that as far as um
well I mean there's a lot of enormous
really fascinating spice stuff about the
British intelligence service and and
sort of early revolutionary Russia and
pre-revolutionary Russia I mean there's
evidence that it was the original
intelligence service who had Rasputin
killed or or a part of part of that that
plot there there's there's a great book
I can't omit the name of the author but
this book called the Russian Roulette
which has a fantastic sort of sort of
edgy edge of COC thriller kind of
neurotic
real historical narrative about those
those early days and the operatives in
that world one of the most interesting
characters who is sort of also featured
in Summerland is HG Wells who plugs into
that as well so he traveled to to rush
her several times and and amongst other
things met with Gorky he also was one of
these hinto nyan
4-dimensional think thinkers and and he
fell madly in love with this woman
called more Abood burg
he was course he was rookies secretarial
stroke lover at the time and and Maura
then later followed Welles to to live in
live with him in London and it's pretty
clear that he was in Italy which he was
an NKVD agent so so HD Welles got sort
of pulled into into weird Soviet British
spy plots also but so there there's a
there's a lot more more to that make
sure hold it close all right listen up
so you said that what sparked this all
off course you were looking for other
sort of historical analogues for the
human experience of accelerating change
was it immediately obvious that the
Victorian era was what real interest it
were there other areas that you sort of
considered or research along the way I
think it was pretty much the one that
attracted me the most because because it
was sort of the closest to modernity
I mean I'm I do come from a physics
background so I find all that found all
these etheric Norley four dimensional
physics endlessly fascinating I mean you
could argue that that there there's
probably a story like this this you
could tell about the Renaissance or sort
of other other periods of history I
guess Middle Ages in the Black Death
we're kind of a kind of a negative
example so sort of sort of bad bad
singularity but but yeah if not the
Victorian era I'd probably look at the
look a look at the Renaissance actually
and so helix nanos sewing machines are
coming out with so you have a whole
other we should say your your work in
synthetic biology is not in the spirit
realm for the most part correct well
what are you what are you doing with
tell us tell us a bit about what
hillocks anno is and how how do you do
you hold those two things in your head
is is are they separate things or their
relations between your fiction and your
scientific work and business work yes oh
so so helix no no he's
started focusing on figuring out
different new new ways to deliver
synthetic genes into into the human body
to to enable us to to reprogram our
biology and cure disease in the new way
I sort of co-founded that with a guy
called Nikolai ischenko who's one of
George church's PhD students so so we're
we have some familiarity with the
mammoth mammoth project through through
George and and instead of being the CEO
Felix knows very much my my my day job
so I typically do my writing writing
early early in the morning but but I am
now working on a new book which sort of
definitely bridges both realms I'm
writing a near future thriller about by
hackers about a teenage girl who joins
an underground by hacker community to to
cure her little brother's cancer so so I
think in that context it's sort of
useful to have some insider knowledge or
deep deep knowledge of what's going on
in synthetic biology and we're almost
out of time but you're gonna stick
around you're gonna sign books you'll
talk to folks please come up and
obviously there's more to talk about and
I'm sure you guys have a lot more
questions let me ask you something so
you have you wrote a story recently
about blockchain which I mentioned in
the intro that for the MIT Technology
Review you also participated as a judge
I think in a contest about you bi
stories it was kind of an open call for
that you know we're big believers at
long now that science fiction is is
inspirational and helps us kind of
culturally we have a great talk by Anna
Lee new it's earlier this year thinking
about how how science fiction is part of
the scientific pursuits but it seems
like this is a more sort of direct
rather than kind of taking inspiration
it's almost like problem-solving
happening in fiction and science fiction
of sort of directly kind of
interrogating a new technology and I
think that Anna Lee talked about you
know kind of modeling it in culture in a
way how do you think about that and does
that seem like a trend and a good trend
to you what are your thoughts especially
being a scientist as well as as a
yeah so I think it's definitely
definitely a trend Karl Schroeder talks
a lot about scenario fiction so taking a
new piece of technology and putting into
it into sort of a context of a human
conflict or or a human problem that the
characters have to solve and I think
that's this can be a very powerful way
to sort of discover interesting failure
modes or at least interesting questions
to ask about future technologies I think
the the power of fiction the power of
narrative that it is that it can in an
immersive way to put us inside these
these imaginary worlds and sort of
especially I mean even though we
obviously have TV and Netflix and so on
I I think written our prose is still
very powerful because it gives us a
unique way to experience that world from
through through somebody's consciousness
from from the inside and I think you can
you can then see things that you'd
otherwise miss I don't think it's very
good for predicting the future I think
it's it's very much about scenarios that
Peter is very familiar with but from
really from sort of human experience or
point of view what would these futures
look like how would they feel like would
we like to live in them I think I think
it's sort of fiction is a great vehicle
for posing those kinds of questions it's
great and Summerland is out now and it
seems to be getting good reception
you're happy with with the that's great
well great well you're gonna stick
around for a bit thanks again to
Borderlands who are selling books in the
back we will have him that and more of
your books back there I have a long now
challenge coin for you encouraging you
to seize the millennium carpe millennium
thank you all for being a great great
audience tonight please do stick around
and come up and ask questions hopefully
get a book and it'll sign it and and
thank you again big round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]